let's talk about the chronic wearing of
masks okay now I can see wearing a mask
in a condensed area especially if
someone's coughing on you and things
like that but a lot of times when I go
out for long walks in in an area where
it's wooded I'm seeing people are just
wearing the mask and they're by
themselves
I see people driving their car by
themselves and they're wearing a mask so
I want to just talk about if that's a
good thing or a bad thing so here's some
things I want to talk about relating to
the mask a mask will restrict the air
flow to your lungs okay and depending on
what type of mask that you're wearing
will determine how much air is getting
through the mask will stress the
respiratory muscles okay around the lung
especially if you are wearing the mask
for a long period of time now the mask
you probably saw me wearing in the in
the thumbnail looks like this is
part of a hypoxic training program where
I'm purposely restricting air flow to my
lungs intermittently for maybe like two
minutes while I'm exercising and
breathing hard and then I'll take it off
back and forth so I'm creating a stress
it's called a hermetic effect where
you're adding stress and letting your
body recover so you can then build up
the muscles around the loan so I know
this is different because you're doing
exercise and of course people wearing
the masks are not necessarily exercising
but sometimes they are as well so the
point I'm trying to make is that if
someone is fragile and they're older and
they're wearing a mask 24/7 that may be
a problem because you're adding more
stress to an area of their body that is
already weakened and they're probably
already susceptible and vulnerable to
getting that virus the point is when
you're in the car by yourself or you're
outside not around people you need to
take that mask off and actually just let
air go in unless you're healthy and
you're trying to get in shape but
definitely you want to go back and forth
if you want to take it off and you want
to put it back on but the fact is if you
put something over your mouth
obstructing the air you're going
to reduce oxygen into the lungs okay so
that's all I'm saying there's different
types of masks that give you different
filtration okay you have the n95 medical
mask gives you 95 percent of filtration
with the pores being point three microns
so it's pretty small that's not a
hundred percent but 95 percent is pretty
good a regular surgical mask will
provide between 60 to 80 percent
filtration if you take a 600
thread-count
pillowcase and you have four layers that
will give you about 60% filtration then
you have those bandanas 100% cotton
bandana four layers will only give you
about 19.5% particle filtration so the
best standard number you're looking for
is a point three micron now the size of
the virus is point one micron now you're
saying well wait a second this virus can
squeeze through this hole pretty easily
because this is three times the size
true but the more filtration you have
the less air you're going to get through
the less you're going to be able to
breathe so there's a toss-up between
getting enough oxygen and filtering out
a virus so you can pretty much put a
plastic bag over your head and get a
hundred percent but of course you're not
going to be able to survive that long so
there's some other factors involved one
is this the virus itself usually is
traveling on a droplet especially if
someone is sneezing coughing breathing
or talking to you so the size of the
droplet okay is much bigger than the
virus because a droplet is composed of
fluid some protein salts other minerals
electrolytes and even microbes so you
have a lot of things kind of like a
little fluid gel that's being projected
in the air so now the viruses are
entrapped in this larger amount of fluid
they're going to be filtered out from
the mask there's always a chance that
you're gonna get some of those viruses
that are gonna get through right but
here's the thing you have also the
variable
of your susceptibility to the virus how
healthy your immune system is and the viral
load or the concentration of viruses so
if there's just a little bit of viral
particles that are getting in your body
and you have a strong immune system
you're going to be able to handle that
with no problem so the sicker you are
and the higher the viral load the more
you need to worry about your mask but if
you're healthy and you're just not being
around people that are sneezing or
coughing your face and you get exposed
to some viruses in the virus load is low
your immune system will deal with it you
might have some very very mild symptoms
so there's a relationship between the
severity of the infection and this right
here the viral load I think the worst
case scenario is if you're a doctor or
nurse working in a hospital and you're
around the concentration of viruses then
you have the velocity of someone else
maybe spreading some viruses on you so
you have the sneeze which could
potentially project between seven and
eight meters that's 23 to 26 feet okay
depending on how strong that sneeze is
or someone's coughing on you that's
between 5 to 6 meters 19 feet it's
pretty strong cough or if they're
breathing on you we're only talking
about 2 meters about 7 feet now this is
the distance that it could potentially
travel of course the greater the
distance the less the viral
concentration but then we have the
droplet particles okay so if someone
sneezing roughly could be around 40,000
droplets
okay versus someone coughing on you
that's 3,000 droplets or someone that's
talking to you for about 30 minutes that
could total about 3,000 droplets so you
can see the concentration down here the
viral load is going to be a lot smaller
than someone sneezing on you so the
reason I'm talking about this is just to
show you the different variables of
velocity your own susceptibility the
viral load the filtration and the time
that you wear the mask if you are weak
and you have a poor immune system
especially if your chronic smoker or you
have COPD chronic obstructive pulmonary
disease or asthma you shouldn't be
wearing this mask all day long anyway
that's my thoughts and now I'm wanna
hear your thoughts tell me what you
think about this topic and link down
below
we're back with another amazing recipe no
grains no sugar
totally keto there's no suffering on
keto absolutely not Karen and it's an
immune system builder absolutely you
have to check this out I think you
should hurry up watch the recipe and
make it yourself it's just so easy to be
keto but is it simple it's super simple
we hope you enjoy making it as much as
we are enjoying eating it